tena
bonjour et bienvenue sur le plateau d'
europe hebdo nous sommes à bruxelles au
parlement le long terme et dans cette
émission nous parlerons des mafias en
europe elles sont tellement puissante
que certains députés européens doivent
vivre sous la protection permanente de
gardes du corps mais d'abord l'actualité
avec la question de l'immigration elle
est centrale
mais personne ne veut la prendre en
charge un tout petit bateau au large des
côtes italiennes
ils sont un peu moins de trente mille à
avoir débarqué sur l'île de lampedusa
depuis le mois de janvier
l'italie leur a accordé un laissez
passer mais la france refuse de les
accueillir et l'europe ne sais pas trop
quoi faire de ses candidats à l'exil
bref la question de l'immigration
embarrasse les états membres car en
l'absence de politique commune
l'accueil des réfugiés relève avant tout
d'une compétence nationale bref chacun
reste maître chez soi et voit midi à sa
porte
il y a quelques années par exemple
l'espagne l'italie ou encore la belgique
régularisait bon nombre de dossiers
d'immigrants illégaux alors que de son
côté la france restait beaucoup plus
ferme en 2008 sous présidence française
un pacte pour harmoniser les politiques
d'asile et d'immigration à l'échelle
européenne avait été proposée trois ans
plus tard il n'est toujours pas en place
et pourtant l'europe reste le premier
continent d'immigration devant
l'amérique du nord
l'enjeu est de taille pour le vieux
continent à la population de plus en
plus âgés d'ici à 2050 il aura perdu 20
millions d'habitants selon le c d e la
population européenne ne pourra donc se
maintenir que grâce à l'immigration
alors devant cette évidence la politique
de l'autruche va-t-elle encore continuer
voilà alors nous sommes avec sylvie
goulard bonjour ou députée européenne
très active hisser au parlement européen
du groupe
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe alors la tension
européenne se focalise depuis des mois
maintenant sur ces quelques 25 mille
migrants venus principalement de tunisie
ce que ce n'est pas un peu l'arbre qui
cache la forêt est ce que de manière
générale l'europe a ou non un problème
avec l'immigration
oui il ya deux choses je crois qu'il
faut dire la première comme le reportage
le faisait bien valoir il s'agit d'un
petit groupe de personnes finalement
mais qui arrive sur une île minuscule
est dans une situation tout à fait
particulière qui est celle des révoltes
arabes
faire de la révolte arabe en tunisie et
puis de ce qui se passe en libye
donc on a affaire à un cas assez
exceptionnel
prenant des proportions tout à fait
particulière en italie mais la question
beaucoup plus large et celle de savoir
comment nous assurons le contrôle de
l'accès à l'union européenne en général
si vous alliez sur la frontière
polonaise vous verrez ce que les
polonais au siphon vis-à-vis des
migrants de l'est en grèce on a tous les
afflux de personnes qui passent via la
turquie là que cette immigration à ce
que toute l'attention et les critiques
se focalisent toujours sur quelque chose
mais le problème demeure la deuxième
chose que je veux dire c'est que il est
quand même aussi très important que nous
décidions en commun
quelle image nous voulons donner de
l'europe dans le monde combien de
personnes nous sommes capables
d'accueillir notamment je le souligne
dans un contexte où nous avons participé
à une guerre en libye qui met peut-être
un certain nombre de gens dans les
bateaux et deuxièmement la tunisie s'est
libérée ce qui est une bonne nouvelle
alors on a l'impression que le discours
est un petit peu hypocrite dans ce
domaine parce que tout le monde se
refile un peu là la patate chaude entre
guillemets enfin le et personne ne veut
assumer ce qui est qualifié comme un
fardeau le fardeau de l'immigration
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
hypocrite ce discours
non seulement ces hypocrites mais c'est
dangereux parce que l'immigration n'est
pas seulement un fardeau moi j'ai envie
de le dire et de le redire dans un
contexte en france et dans d'autres
états membres qui commence à devenir
odieux nous avons des personnes qui
des circonstances vraiment difficile et
qui cherche par leur travail
un avenir ça ne signifie pas qu'on va
tout les accueillir en europe mais je
pense qu'il faut cesser de faire peur
aux populations vieillissantes de
l'europe en leur parlant de hordes qui
ont envie de venir s'installer chez nous
quiconque connaît la tunisie beaucoup de
français connaissent la tunisie savent
très bien que si on a le choix on
préfère sans doute vivre dans un pays
aussi aussi beau et agréable que de
venir s'entasser dans des banlieues du
nord de l'europe
la vraie question c'est comment arrives
en nous à aider les économies de la rive
sud de la méditerranée de manière à ce
que l'agriculture le tourisme
l'industrie reprenne et que ces
populations aient vocation à terme à
rester dans leur pays
en clair l'europe doit tirer les
conséquences n'a pas encore tiré les
conséquences de ce printemps arabe
d'abord elle aurait dû l'anticiper mieux
je rappelle que le président de la
république avait lancé un projet d'union
de la méditerranée que pour ma part j'ai
critiqué à l'époque dans un livre en
2008 parce qu'il consistait à traiter
avec des personnes qui étaient des
tyrans et des dictateurs corrompus on le
savait on a fermé les yeux
on était bien content que monsieur
kadhafi et d'autres monsieur ben ali et
encore d'autres fassent la police à nos
portes
quelles que soient les méthodes qu'ils
employaient dieu merci grâce à la
libéralisation de tous ces jeunes
nous ne sommes plus dans cette situation
et j'avais envie de faire une remarque
ya un décalage absolument fabuleux entre
la liberté qui s'exprime dans ces pays
là la manière dont on utilise les
réseaux sociaux sans frontières et la
réponse que des équipes vieillissantes
au pouvoir en europe à pause qui est
d'aller mettre des guérites à vintimille
entre la france et l'italie effacés
ridicule ça n'est à l'évidence pas la
solution qu'il faut pour régler ce
problème
alors comment régler ce problème
notamment de deux frontières de ce ce
qu'il faut remettre en cause l espace
schengen
ce qu'il faudrait par exemple des
garde-côtes européen c'est une idée qui
circule depuis depuis quelques années ce
que ça sachant qu'au niveau il ya le
caractère exceptionnel actuel est là qu
entre la france et l'italie demande
qu'on réfléchisse ensemble à la manière
dont on interprète le traité de schengen
je crois qu'il y à une demande légitime
il faut y répondre
deuxièmement il ne faut pas toucher à la
libre circulation qui est l'un des
fondements de l'union européenne et je
rappellerai quand même aux français que
si l'île la plus proche de la tunisie et
la libye est et la corse
nous ne considérions probablement pas
cela comme un problème français donc il
faut arrêter d'être hypocrite et
troisièmement j'y reviens même si c'est
difficile même si ça peut paraître naïf
et de long terme nous devons valoriser
le développement du sud ce n'est qu'en
proposant une vie chez eux en
investissant dans ces pays
rappelons nous que les américains ont
fait avec le plan marshall après la
seconde guerre mondiale pour aider
l'europe à se développer et il faut
aussi de des bonnes volontés de l'argent
on pensait que que certains pays que
l'europe est prête à ça que les
paiements sont sales et l'argent ou vous
investissez à moyen terme ou après vous
êtes obligé de le dépenser dans de
mauvaises conditions trop tard pour ma
part je pense qu'encore une fois sans
aller à des montants énormes
nous pourrions essayer de pousser des
micro projets avec ces pays là en accord
avec la société civile d'ailleurs de 60
tunisie pour l'instant il ya même pas
encore de gouvernement constitué ils
sont en train d'adopter de nouvelles
institutions
on a pendant des années déverser de
l'argent qui sont allés dans les mains
d'un certain nombre de dictateurs
corrompus je crois qu'on peut trouver de
l'argent pour aider ces pays là encore
une fois en tenant compte du contexte
d'austérité en europe mais en leur
faisant aussi un peu confiance et en
misant sur leur potentiel d'avenir
merci beaucoup sylvie goulard d'avoir
été sur le plateau d'europe et dont on
poursuit à la une des télévisions
européennes la mort d'oussama ben laden
tué par un commando américain petit tour
d'horizon des télés d'europe regarder
bonsoir ce soir je peux annoncer au
peuple américain et au monde que les
etats-unis ont mené une opération qui a
permis ni faire de tuer oussama ben
laden le chef d'al qaïda le trucage
réalisé à partir d'une image de ben
laden vivant et de l'image d'un autre
homme au visage tuméfié aurait été
réalisé dès 2006 la photo est ressorti
comme par miracle ce matin après
l'annoncé par les etats-unis de la mort
du leader terroriste pour les victimes
des attentats
justice a été faite mais les partisans
de ben laden le pleure un martyr et
entendent continuer son combat
nous avons un niveau d alerte anti
terroriste ou déjà très haut
nous pensons que ce n'est pas nécessaire
de relever ce niveau c'est suffisant
pour garantir la sécurité des citoyens
espagnols
cette nouvelle sera saluée partout dans
notre pays mais cela ne signifie pas que
nous en avons fini avec la menace du
terrorisme islamique et nous serons
particulièrement vigilants dans les
semaines à venir
mais aujourd'hui en tout cas à grand pas
a été accompli et nous avons été
rejoints par marcello faradji bonjour
vous êtes gauche demandant à bruxelles
vous suivez les affaires européennes
depuis des années alors on a entendu des
réactions plutôt assez enthousiaste sur
sur ces événements peut-on faut-il
vraiment se réjouir de la mort d'un
homme
le cpr soda symbole très importante et
mais ça veut pas dire que l'histoire du
terrorisme est finie et déjà on voit
aussi à un problème du propagande parce
que c'était presque génial comment on
pouvait tout suivre en détail mais les
et réactions ont été parfois aussi
exempts
oui celle d'angela merkel par exemple
qui a dit qu'elle était heureuse
d'apprendre cette nouvelle
exactement je crois il voudrait pas
répéter cette phrase parce qu'elle était
fortement maintenant critiqué parce que
on peut je crois c'est vrai on peut
jamais être heureux qu'on ne porte qui
va perdre sa vie et en plus dans des
démocraties comme les nôtres on pense
plutôt à des procédures juridiques et la
loi n'est ce pas alors avec la mort 2
ça n'avait de la dance sept mois ne
signifie pas pour autant la fin du
terrorisme islamique notamment est ce
que vous pensez que il ya des menaces de
représailles notamment en europe
oui ça va continuer malheureusement
parce que on vit dans un monde que
c'était jamais la paix totale et il faut
pas croire que c'est une personne seule
qui dirige tout ouïe pour nous que
médias il nous faut toujours une tête
alors c'est plus facile à expliquer à
tous dirigés vers une tête mais quand
j'ai travaillé j'ai fait mes recherches
en italie et d'autres pays
après l'attentât aux états unis j'étais
aussi impressionné combien de personnes
ont été tordus ils vont vers le
terrorisme et ceux ils sont pas disparus
si vous avez des exemples précis a cité
des exemples de précis c'est toujours
dangereux est là et vous vous devez
avoir des preuves ça commençait déjà
vous souvenez par exemple vous avez reçu
non et on n'a pas trouvé par exemple
d'une adresse parce que y avait des
plusieurs moyens façon d'écrire ce nom
là par exemple non ça commence avec mon
nom aussi faradji vous avez plusieurs
façon de l'écrire et c'est déjà
difficile à conduire une recherche
exact quels moyens l'europe a
aujourd'hui de lutter contre une menace
une telle menace
si global 6,6 imperceptible il ya deux
niveaux ramène à partir de niveaux si
vous voulez un niveau pour rassurer le
grand public par exemple on impose des
contrôles à l'aéroport
on parle par exemple de nouveau être des
de contrôle douanières et ça pour donner
l'air que donc on peut tout surveiller
mais honnêtement c'est pas ça qu'on vous
parlait avec des experts c'est plutôt
des moyens plus intelligent de haut
niveau par exemple l'informatique pour
voir quels sont les réseaux avec les
portables avec l'internet et c'est là où
il ya un échange d informations
douteuses
en attendant d'aider un renforcement des
mesures de protection un risque de se
trouver des entreprises
est-ce que jusqu'où peut aller cette
privation de liberté en fait quelle est
la juste mesure entre tout faire pour
assurer la sécurité des citoyens et
respecter leur liberté si vous avez 100%
de sécurité vous allez emprisonné si
vous voulez les citoyens et là vous
pouvez dire alors les terroristes ont
gagné ils vont aussi gagner alors je
crois la priorité c'est clair il faut
laisser et garder la liberté des
citoyens et
et toujours réfléchir jusqu'où on peut
aller pour assurer la société merci
beaucoup
marcello faradji d'avoir été avec nous
cette semaine on s'intéresse au combat
d'un homme celui de rosario crocetta
député européen il lutte contre la mafia
italienne
il est menacé de mort regardez ce
reportage réalisé en sicile avec patrick
amand scène qui a suivi ce député
nous sommes à jeddah dans le sud de la
sicile nous suivons ses deux voitures
dans l'une d'elles se trouve rosario
crocetta il est connu pour son combat
contre la mafia
quand il était maire de la ville
résultat ici en cinq ans il a contribué
à mettre plus de 900 mafieux derrière
les barreaux depuis celui qui se définit
comme chrétien communiste est fier
d'être gay vit en permanence sous la
protection de cinq gardes du corps comme
un président de la république
aujourd'hui ils seront une exposition
consacrée à la lutte contre la mafia
une prise de risque rosario crocetta et
condamne à mort par l'organisation du
crime
il a déjà échappé à plusieurs tentatives
d'assassinats pour lui tous les outils
sont bons pour combattre son ennemi et
des halles à la politique mais il ya
l'art de la couture
kenney demanderesse importants de
transformation sociale parce que nous ne
demande pas seulement faire arrêter des
mafias semaines doit chercher les têtes
des gens est là avec la culture de la
presse et des positions en peinture elle
sa empêché beaucoup et pour cat et
changer les mentalités pour gagner le
soutien de l'opinion
un objectif qui aurait un prix le
sacrifice d'une vie à l'image des juges
falcone et borsellino assassiné par la
mafia rosario crocetta est-il un héros
les héros vous savez deviennent des
héros quand il meurt quand ils vivent
eh bien ce sont des citoyens comme les
autres et aujourd'hui rosario crocetta
n'est pas un héros il est un homme libre
qui fait son devoir
être condamné à mort par la mafia
rosario crocetta acceptent-ils ce destin
non non je ne sais pas mais je ne peux
pas accepter que ma vie la date de ma
mort a été décidée pas vers par des gens
et moi j'ai fait la news comme ça à
chaque déplacement c'est le même
scénario voiture blindée en escorte
bref une liberté de mouvement très
limité
martial est libre matt est évident et ça
compte beaucoup plus qu'il ya des bété
et la liberté pour un homme politique
c'est d'abord la transparence en termes
de travaux publics
rosario crocetta nous emmène devant le
nouveau palais de justice de jay là
qu'il a sauvée d'un financement mafieux
un exemple à méditer pour l'europe on a
un paradoxe qu une entreprise liée à la
mafia ne peut pas gagner en appel
d'offres ainsi s'il est va gagner et bah
gagner à paris à berline à bruxelles ça
veut dire ça il y à une législation
européenne qui n'a pas encore
intériorisé le fait que la mafia s'est
globalisé
une loi européenne contre la mafia voilà
ce que demande rosario crocetta la
journée se termine pour notre député un
jour de plus s'arracher à la sentence de
la mafia un espoir de plus pour un homme
libre voilà donc pour ce reportage
réalisé en sicile nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec michael roudaut bonjour
alors vous êtes un spécialiste du crime
organisé du phénomène du crime organisé
en europe
est-ce que ce qu'on vient de voir
actuellement avec ce député européen
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
étonne est ce que le phénomène des
mafias en europe est un phénomène qui
prend de l'ampleur
alors quand on parle de mafia il faut
déjà pouvoir définir le terme les mafias
sont une société criminels secrète qui
recrutent ou des bases claniques qui
sont plus récentes nerfs est en fait le
terme de mafia correspond à
l'aristocratie du crime organisé
elles sont peu nombreuses en europe mais
à quatre en italie ensuite à mafia
albanophone la mafia turque
les triades chinoises li à khouza si
bien qu est la mafia italo américaine
si bien qu'en fait si on doit parler de
mafia leur présence
évidemment transnational est tout même
circonscrite sur un territoire
alors quand juste pardon une petite
parenthèse en ce qui concerne rosario
cours de cette année ce député européen
quand il arrivait ici à bruxelles
il ya une polémique parce qu'il avait
demandé à être protégés et les autorités
belges ont mis un petit peu de temps je
dirais à prendre en charge sa demande
est ce que même ici j'ai à dire au coeur
de l'europe que ce soit à bruxelles ou
même éventuellement à strasbourg est-ce
que ce député européen ou d'autres parce
qu'il y en a d'autres sont réellement en
danger
potentiellement oui on l'a vu avec ce
qui s'est passé à lisbourg en allemagne
la langue greta tout à fait la
possibilité comme n'importe quel réseau
de criminels et mafieux la possibilité
d'organiser un assassinat quel que soit
l'endroit en europe tout à fait qu'est
ce que peut faire l'europe pour lutter
contre les mafias
nous sommes actuellement dans une
période charnière pour la lutte contre
le crime organisé
nous avons désormais le traité de
lisbonne nous avons le programme de
stockholm et nous assistons à une
pénétration accrue qui organisait dans
la sphère licite due à un accroissement
de la pression agressive c'est à dire eh
bien c'est à dire puisque nous avons
désormais 10 av s'apprécie mieux formées
avec des outils plus efficaces
le crime organisé recherche un anonymat
en se cachant derrière des façades légal
en investissant dans l'économie licite
en blanchissant l'argent de leur trafic
et pour lutter plus efficacement la
chose n'a pas changé c'est mieux
échanger l'information le renseignement
le saint graal et sa mise après cif
c'est là dessus c'est sur le
renseignement que l'europe peut agir
tout à fait l'ambition c'est de faire en
sorte que re paul sont en mesure non
simplement d'échanger l'information
traitement mais surtout de l'enrichir
l'enrichir pour le restituer aux états
membres afin d'améliorer la vision et la
compréhension qu'ils ont ces réseaux
criminels ou 10x est plus en plus de
services et qui est un de plus en plus
de services compétents est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un peu quels sont les
services qui au niveau européen lutte
contre le crime organisé parce qu'on
voit bien ce qui peut se passer au
niveau des tirs et des autorités de
police nationales au niveau européen
c'est un peu plus compliqué au niveau
européen nous avons europol nous avons
eurojust
nous avons aussi de l'afld ne l'a fait
compétent pour la protection des
intérêts financiers l'union européenne
ça concerne notamment le trafic de
cigarettes ça concerne tout ce qui
touche graphique d'essence par exemple
europol et compétent pour l'ensemble de
l'investissement du crime organisé dans
tout ce qui est trafics criminels marché
criminel est heureux juste pour le volet
coopération judiciaire est ce que tous
ces organismes coopèrent entre ils
coopèrent entre niveau européen tout à
fait efficacement ce qu'il faut assurer
désormais c'est une meilleure
coopération entre états membres
ce que l'on constate avec la création du
marché intérieur c'est qu'il n'existe
plus de frontières aujourd'hui pour
assurer les flux des trafics de
marchandises de personnes de service par
contre ses frontières demeurent pour le
policier et pour le juge il s'agit d'y
remédier
alors on n'a pas beaucoup parlé dans la
première partie de cette émission de
schengen de l'espace schengen est ce que
justement le fait qu'il n'y ait plus de
frontières intérieures
est-ce que ça facilite le travail du
crime organisé disons que c'est un
facteur qui peut en théorie faciliter le
travail des réseaux criminels dans la
mesure où s'il a plus de frontières ils
peuvent passer d'un état membre à un
autre
néanmoins avec une meilleure coopération
ils ne sont pas à l'abri des poursuites
d'un état membre à un autre alors mais
quelle roue doit voir partir un instant
en sicile on va retrouver rosario
crocetta ce député européen vous allez
voir il a une suggestion à faire on les
côtes et doit était obligatoire déclaré
la l'origine de l'âge il faut des lois
passent sous les appels d'offres pour
les contrôler mais faut une loi pour le
père cours de l'argent pour regarder le
parcours de l'argent parce que c'est
arrivé quelques uns des grands vins ban
que maintenant ce sont deux demandes et
bat pau c'est un million d euros sont
demandés où arrive peut arriver c'est
millions d euros alors voilà comment est
ce qu'on peut suivre le tracé de
l'argent sale est ce que vous avez une
réponse à lui apporter là dessus la
commission est très active
nous avons la troisième directive anti
blanchiment nous aurons une quatrième
directive anti blanchiment
il s'agit dans ce cadre là de faire en
sorte notamment avec le développement
des investigations financières de
pouvoir assurer ce suivi justement de
l'argent développe les investigations
financières renforcer la compétence des
services répressifs renforcer leurs
capacités et leur expertise à suivre cet
argent pour pouvoir justement ce que je
vous expliquais
de l'interview pour être en mesure
d'identifier comment le crime organisé
se dissimule dans l'économie licite
alors michael woods est je le rappelle
un auteur de de ce livre qui s'appelle
marché criminel un acteur global ses
opus est ce que le fait que le crime
organisé soit de plus en plus
professionnels et donc de plus en plus
efficace est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui est prise en compte des envies dire
est ce que les autorités européennes
progressent aussi vite aussi vite que le
crime organisé
c'est une logique darwinienne donc
effectivement au fur à mesure que le
crime organisé se professionnalise
la réponse policière également il répond
et ceci parce qu'il ya un an ça
fonctionne vraiment tout à fait mais pas
simplement d'une logique réactiver aussi
proactive et là dessus de nouveaux
outils se développent afin de développer
une approche préventive
aujourd'hui ce que le crime organisé en
2011 est ce que le crime organisé est
plus puissant ou moins puissants qu'il
ya dix ans par exemple
c'est difficile de lire de façon
générale parce qu'on a affaire à des
courbes qui sont autonome et donc quand
un groupe disparaît un autre peut
émerger et se développer de façon
générale on peut dire que tu néanmoins
certains marchés criminels se développe
on dit que par exemple le crime organisé
s'il était un état où et blu ray la
puissance justement d'un état il devrait
rentrer au g8 c'est vrai
effectivement effectivement si on devait
considérer l'économie criminelle en tant
que tel au niveau global comme étant
une économie licite elle aurait la
puissance d'un état qui pourraient
prétendre dé facto à une place au sein
du g8 mais qu'elles ont dit merci
beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation
on en rêve de rester avec nous on va
maintenant parler de l'europe au
quotidien comme on le fait chaque
semaine avec cette question d'un
téléspectateur aujourd'hui il s'agit
d'une question de marque de bordeaux il
nous dit mon ami et moi nous sommes
pacsés
nous voudrions aller vivre dans un autre
pays européen
est ce que tous les pays européens
doivent reconnaître notre pacs voici la
réponse d'europe direct qui n'ont pas
d'une civile tels que l'espace ce
matignon à la reconnaître
le seul avantage que vous serez c'est
que votre pacte peuvent être considérés
comme preuve des relations durables
ce qui signifie que si vous voulez aller
travailler dans une autre des frères
partenaire peut vous accompagner sans
devoir remplir d'autres conditions
voilà ici vous aussi bien vous voulez
poser une question à l'europe direct
vous pouvez le faire par téléphone
c'est gratuit de partout en europe ou
composez le 0 0 800 6 7 8 9 10 11 voilà
merci encore michael roudaut et c'est la
fin d'europe abdou bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires